I don't care what you are get your kids  to go to church today because at least  the conservative values are being taught  there's never been if you can't afford  private school if you can't afford a  homeschooling you can't afford to take  your kids to a local church and get them  involved kids need a lot more now don't  get me wrong I know people are going to  come back and say look what happened to  the Catholic church and all this other  stuff totally get it I understand what  you're saying all I'm saying to you is  in a controlled fashion get your kids  around learning solid values their kids  are needing that more because public  schools are definitely not teaching that  today